what are things to look for when you're
debating whether to raise your voice or
yell do to those under you being lazy or
unmotivated you all talk a lot about the
importance of self-control and not just
losing it but would you say there's a
time and place for raising the intensity
while still being respectful towards
your guys so there you go yelling and
screaming get some sometimes you got to
just drop the hammer
Jaakko yelled and screamed at us all the
time I've talked about on this you know
I think on the podcast we started
talking about all the time I mean the
number of times that Jocko screamed and
yelled at me zero zero times in all the
years that we work together and I know I
gave him at least dozens maybe hundreds
of opportunities to want to probably
done that and he didn't do that because
he realized it wasn't effective
so now listen there there is there is a
time where you know if there's a major
safety issue going on and you're trying
to get people's attention and you want
people a ceasefire or you need to rally
the troops where you got to raise your
voice and get people's attention and I
think that's you can't be afraid to do
that so there are certainly times rights
a life those probably signed up over
there or stuff like that I mean for sure
that's is that yelling well yeah I'm
definitely raising my voice and using a
loud voice but I'm not doing it whatever
with anger it's just hey you got to hear
me and so and also you know there is
times where you've got to you've got to
pick up the intensity in your voice so
that people realize there's something
important happening right there's just
enough now you don't want to eat yell
and scream and get all crazy but to be
like hey I need vehicles here now like
that is different than hey can you get
the vehicles over here now right those
are two different things and you I would
react differently if I heard those two
voices so yes now to go over you now no
one now we're creating a whole panic
situation but that's a great point too
right and it's it's the kind of you know
never cry wolf you know so when you're
if you're yelling all the time how do
you do this vehicles over here right now
when there's nothing at stake and it's
no big deal and it's just a routine
movement you know then when you do that
and you really need it then no one's
paying attention they they go
just laughs yelling again into the radio
so so I think that's another reason why
I actually have seen Jocko raised his
voice on one occasion yeah yeah and when
there was a serious issue that needed to
be addressed and you needed to get the
person's attention to show just how
serious of a situation it was and it got
everybody's attention it got everybody's
attention right away because you never
did that and when you did do it it was
like oh man yeah and I was always tell
that to leaders like being on the radio
and this good goes for being in a
meeting right if you go to a meeting if
you're in charge of a meeting and you
talk the whole time and then you have
something important to the to say at the
end well that's great
but it's not as impactful as when you
say very few things during the meeting
and then at the end you say hey guys
listen up here's what's going on with us
and everyone everyone pays attention so
I've said this before the less you talk
the more people listen and that goes
true here the more you yell the less
people listen and it takes away the
opportunity if you ever do have to yell
it's gonna have zero impact so my
blanket statement is you should hardly
ever have to raise your voice and you
should just barely ever happen